hi my name is Eve and it's my voice you
hear when you ring the automated payment
line by simply calling 0162 621 53 53
you compare your council tax
non-domestic ways penalty charge notices
or any invoice received from us you can
also use this service to buy a car
parking permit when you dial the number
0 1 6 2 6 215 353 I will explain
step-by-step the details you need to
enter into your telephone keypad you
will always need to enter the unique
reference number that is on your bill
ticket or invoice so you need to have
these to hand the system accepts all
debit and credit cards except diners
club and American Express it's free to
use this service if you pay with a debit
card however there is a one-point-seven
percent surcharge on all credit card
payments unless you are paying a penalty
charge notice by using the automated
payment line you'll be helping team
bridge save money it costs the council
on average two pounds 35 pence every
time a bill is paid in person by check
or by phone call made to one of our
customer service advisors this all adds
up to thousands of pounds which could be
spent on essential services if you
experience any problems using this
service please call oh 16 26 36 double
101 and one of my colleagues will help
you